wir schauen schon mal auf den nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt da geht es um einen
Entschließungsantrag also einen Antrag
zu einer Regierungserklärung durch den
Bundeskanzler das war eine Erklärung zum
Europäischen Rat noch Ende Juni die
Unionsfraktion hatte diesen
Entschließungsantrag eingereicht in dem
sie die Bundesregierung auffordert auch
schwere Waffen an die Ukraine zu
liefernder nach für Nachschub zu
sorgen damals wollten hier die
Abgeordneten nicht direkt dazu abstimmen
sondern haben sich dafür ausgesprochen
den erst einmal an die entsprechenden
Ausschüsse zu überweisen deswegen wird
dieser Entschließungsantrag jetzt wieder
hier besprochen und als erstes spricht
dazu Robin Wagner für die Krönung
Panzerhaubitzen geliefert Gepard
geliefert
Raketenwerfer geliefert meine Damen und
Herren von der Union dieser Antrag ist
es schon peinlich dass sie den jetzt
wieder zur Abstimmung vorlegen die
Beschlussvorlage entbehrt jeder
beschlussgrundlage
in Dauerschleife in Dauerschleife liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen tun sie mit
ihren schaufensteranträgen zu
Waffenlieferung so als sei die Union der
größte Unterstützer der Ukraine mit
Waffenlieferung das sind sie in Wahrheit
nicht
[Applaus]
auf übelste Weise auf übelste Weise hat
ihr Partei und Fraktionsvorsitzender
gerade wieder Menschen die vermehrt die
alles verloren haben ihr Eigentum
ihr Zuhause
ihren Job ihre Freunde ihre Väter ihre
Angehörigen das sind Rufe aus der
schlimmsten Ecke der Parteienlandschaft
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
CDU schämen sie sich der Kreml dankt
ihnen für diesen Propaganda Quatsch
ihnen geht es ja einzig und allein mit
den Anträgen darum den Keil in die
Koalition reinzutreiben und ich war
nachdem wir hier das erste Mal über die
Sachen beraten haben selber in Kiew und
dort versteht man die Opposition
Scharmützel nicht die sie hier machen
lediglich die falsche weil vollkommen
verkürzte Botschaft bleibt hängen der
Bundestag würde weitere
Waffenlieferungen für die Ukraine
ablehnen diese Botschaft schwächt die
Ukraine und stärkte in Kreml und Sie
sollten ihrer Fraktion mal klären ob sie
dieses Spiel weiter treiben wollen
aber gleichzeitig liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen müssen wir natürlich auch
überlegen ob wir es der Union nicht auch
manchmal zu leicht machen es ist ein
offenes Geheimnis dass wir
unterschiedliche Auffassungen zur
Intensität der militärischen
Unterstützung der Ukraine auch hier im
Bundestag und auch in der Koalition
haben angesichts der fortdauernden
russischen Kriegsverbrechen brauchen wir
mehr Schutz mehr Geschwindigkeit mehr
Schlagkraft für die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte und dazu führen wir die
konstruktiven Gespräche in der Ampel
weil wir nur so die Ukraine vor der
faschistoiden Diktatur und ihrem
genozidahlen Angriffskrieg schützen
können und sie verteidigen können unsere
Unterstützung macht dabei ein
Unterschied vor Ort auch übrigens im
Kopf vieler Russen denn die ehrliche
Abstimmung über diesen Krieg die findet
auch gerade tatsächlich woanders statt
nicht durch Putins scheinen oder
Schwindel oder Lügen Referenten was
immer Sie sagen wollen sondern durch die
Abstimmung mit den Füßen derjenigen
Russen die sich für Putins Wahnsinn
nicht mehr zur Verfügung stellen wollen
und es ist auch unsere Unterstützung die
deren Wahrnehmung über die Sinnlosigkeit
des Krieges prägen und sie zur Flucht
verleiten
aber eins muss uns natürlich hier auch
allen klar sein wenn wir die Ukraine
schützen dann schützen wir auch uns und
die Stimme der Ministerin Lambrecht
ausdrücklich zu wenn sie sagt dass wir
der europäischen Friedensordnung zu
neuer Kraft verhelfen müssen für mich
bedeutet das dass wir gemeinsam und im
transatlantischen Verbund mit unseren
internationalen Partnern einmal mehr
über die qualitative und quantitative
Steigerung unserer Unterstützung beraten
müssen Deutschland hat die
wirtschaftlichen politischen und
militärischen Fähigkeit eine solche
unterstützungsallianz anzuführen
[Applaus]
Putin hat in den letzten Tagen keine
300.000 Mann starke
Verhandlungsdelegation mobilisiert er
will den militärischen Druck ohne
Rücksicht auf Verluste auch auf das den
Verlust des Lebens seiner Landsleute
Wladimir Putin ist und bleibt die größte
Gefahr für russischsprachige Menschen
der Welt die Ukraine braucht unsere
Unterstützung die müssen wir ausweiten
ihren Antrag natürlich ablehnen vielen
Dank
Robin Wagener war das und hier im
plenarsa sind doch noch ziemlich viele
Plätze frei das dürfte sich allerdings
ändern denn die über diesen
Entschließungsantrag wird namentlich
abgestimmt jetzt spricht Johann David
badepool für die Unionsfraktion vielen
Dank für die klaren Aussagen Herr
Kollege Wagner die auch der
Bundeskanzlerin letzten Tagen noch
einmal öffentlich wiederholt hat zur
Qualifizierung der sogenannten
Referenten scheinreferenten die dort
durchgeführt werden das Bekenntnis zur
Unterstützung der Ukraine
der klaren Qualifizierung eines
völkerrechtswidrigen Krieges den
Wladimir Putin führt mir ist wichtig
auch zu Beginn dieser Debatte und der
Abstimmung die wir nachher durchführen
werden die Gemeinschaft die gemeinsame
Betrachtungsweise die die Ampelkoalition
mit der größten Oppositionsfraktion der
cdu/csu-fraktion teilt hier heraus zu
streichen weil ja noch Rednerinnen und
Redner von ganz links und ganz rechts
kommt ist es mir schon wichtig auch zu
betonen dass wir in den zentralen
Einschätzungen dieses Krieges und den
Folgerungen die daraus zu ziehen sind
übereinstimmen und das ist auch gut so
dennoch ist diese Abstimmung notwendig
und ich bin nach wie vor etwas
unglücklich darüber und will das ja auch
zum Ausdruck bringen dass sie einen eine
Abstimmung hier auch im Deutschen
Bundestag so herabqualifizieren und
einen Antrag von vornherein zum
schaufensterantrag disqualifizieren der
Kollege Schmied hat in der letzten Woche
sogar das Abschnitt das die den Antrag
der Union das abzustimmen als schäbig
bezeichnet meine lieben Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich glaube sie müssen hier
parlamentsverständnis überdenken hier
ist der Ort der politischen
Meinungsbildung in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ist eine Errungenschaft dass
das hier stattfinden kann und wir
sollten nicht sage ich Ihnen in aller
Ernsthaftigkeit auch ruf an insbesondere
von ganz rechts
die sie ja zurecht bei vielen
Gelegenheiten auch mal wieder
adressieren hier Futter geben und in den
Chor dieser schmutzigen Rufer einstimmen
die das Parlament disqualifizieren und
meines gebe irgendeinen höheren Ort der
politischen Meinungsbildung als hier
nein hier der Deutsche Bundestag muss
entscheiden und wir sind ja nun Herr
Kollege Wagner beide Juristen und haben
gelernt insbesondere im zivilrechtlichen
Bereich unserer Ausbildung streitigen
von unstreitigem Sachverhalt zu
unterscheiden und dass sie das
hervorragend können hat ja
sieht man ja schon daran dass sie den
herausgehobenen Beruf des Richters
ausgeübt haben bevor sie hier eingezogen
sind und es ist ja völlig unstreitig
zwischen uns
dass die das Deutschland schon viel
leistet dass Deutschland Panzerhaubitzen
liefert das Deutschland geht Paten
geliefert hat und vieles andere mehr
aber es ist eben streitig und darauf
sind sie überhaupt nicht eingegangen und
dazu gibt es ja eine Meinung in ihrer
Koalition dass Deutschland eben keine
Schützenpanzer insbesondere liefert
keine transportpanzerfuchs liefert und
keine Kampfpanzer liefert das ist eben
halt der streitige Punkt und was ist
daran eigentlich Schaufenster
Schaufenster ist an der ganzen
Geschichte nur das Vertreterinnen und
Vertreter ihrer Fraktion und
insbesondere der FDP-Fraktion dafür
immer wieder in Talkshows eintreten aber
hier im Deutschen Bundestag fehlt es an
Bekennermut Frau Kollegin Frank
Zimmermann sie überbieten sich ja von
Talkshow zu Talkshow aber hier bekennen
sie sich nicht sie haben in der letzten
Sitzung Frau Kollegin Frank Zimmermann
noch mal ausdrücklich gesagt
ausdrücklich gesagt und ich zitiere sie
ja meine Damen und Herren wir als Freie
Demokraten sind der Meinung dass wir in
der jetzigen militärischen Lage in der
die ukrainische Armee Stück für Stück
den Territorium zurückholt mindestens
den Transportpanzer Fuchs und den
Schützenpanzer Mardern liefern müssen
Zitat Ende recht haben die Frau stark
Zimmermann stimmen sie so ab wie Sie
denken stimmen sie so ab wie Sie denken
wie sie sich hier äußern und wenn sie
sich was ja in Koalition stellen sich ja
nur zwei Folge Fragen stellen sich ja
nur zwei vorgefragen entweder ist ihr
politisches Gewicht und auch das
derjenigen die sich von der Fraktion der
Grünen und übrigens auch der Kollege
Roth beispielsweise dazu äußern so
gering innerhalb der Koalition dass sie
sich nicht durchsetzen können oder sie
wollen sich überhaupt gar nicht
durchsetzen es gibt ja noch nicht mal
ein Koalitionsausschuss zu dieser Frage
über alle möglichen Fragen gibt es
koalitionsausschüsse über eine so
wichtige Frage
eine so existenzielle Frage ja ich will
andere Fragen dadurch nicht
disqualifizieren aber diese Frage hat
eine ganz hohe Bedeutung und gerade
Waffenlieferung in ein Kriegsgebiet sind
natürlich eine schwierige Frage das ist
doch vollkommen klar aber wo ist hier um
Menschenleben wirklich darum geht ob man
zur Ukraine steht da kriegen sie es noch
nicht mal hin Olaf Scholz mindestens zum
Koalitionsausschuss zu zwingen so wenig
wichtig ist ihnen das Bekenntnis dass
sie immer wieder öffentlich äußern
und ich möchte sagen der Bundeskanzler
hat jetzt noch mal gesagt
keinerlei Gang
dazu ist mal als allererstes zu sagen
allein Gänge sind immer schlecht das ist
vollkommen klar aber ehrlich gesagt nach
dem Maßstab ist die Lieferung des
flugabwehrkanonenpanzers Gepard ein
Alleingang denn keiner liefert so ein
Waffensystem mit zwei 35 mm Kanonen in
der Durchschlagskraft viel mehr als ein
Marder an Kampfkraft auf dem
Gefechtsfeld hätte das ist ein
Alleingang meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren das Argument ist in sich von
vornherein schon falsch und zweitens hat
der Bundeskanzler und das sagen sie ja
auch immer wieder und ihr
Parteivorsitzender das ist in einer Rede
vor der Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung auch
noch mal für sich selber und für seine
Partei eingefordert sie reden immer von
der Führungsrolle
Führungsrolle Deutschland wäre doch in
dieser Situation mindestens die
Initiative zu ergreifen die Michael Roth
vorgeschlagen hat dass man im Konzert
abgestimmt mit anderen europäischen
amerikanischen Verbündeten
diesen Lieferung kommt noch nicht einmal
diese Rolle nehmen sie war und auch hier
versagt die Bundesregierung Deutschland
versagt die Bundesregierung und darüber
muss abgestimmt werden hier ist ihr
Bekennermut heute in diesem Haus
gefordert daran werden wir sie messen
dankeschön
den Fingern die Wunde legen das ist ja
Aufgabe der Opposition und wadepool hat
das hier ja sehr deutlich gemacht denn
gerade
verteidigungspolitikerin marie-agne
Strack Zimmermann von der FDP hat eben
unter anderem auch schon gefordert
schützen und Kampfpanzer westlicher
Bauart zu liefern und steht damit in
Kontrast zu einigen in der SPD-Fraktion
für die spricht jetzt Ralf stiegener
veranstaltet gefakte Volksabstimmung den
besetzten Gebieten er schickt weitere
tausende junge Russen in den Tod erwerft
Bomben auf die zivile Infrastruktur und
Wohngebäude er lässt seine Schergen
foltern plündern und vergewaltigen und
wer weiß noch wer hinter diesen
gefährlichen Sabotageakten gegen die
europäische Energieinfrastruktur steckt
in dieser Lage ist nicht so wichtig wie
gute Vorbereitung ein kühler Kopf
Entschlossenheit aber auch Besonderheit
ist das ein richtiges Parlament und
öffentlicher Debatte immer wieder
diskutieren wie und in welchem Umfang
wir der Ukraine am besten helfen können
damit Putin mit seinem imperialistischen
Angriffskrieg nicht durchkommt
gleichzeitig tragen wir aber auch
Verantwortung dafür dass der Krieg sich
nicht weiter ausdehnt dass wir Putin
ernst nehmen ohne in Angststarre zu
verfallen und auf seiner Propaganda und
den Leim auf den Leim zu gehen das ist
auch alles vorbereitet sind aber auch
alles dafür tun dass es keinen Krieg
gibt zwischen der NATO und der atomacht
Russland dass wir solidarisch mit der
Ukraine senden zugleich die Sorgen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ernst nehmen
Angst vor einem versehentlichen Angriff
auf das Atomkraftwerk einen neuen
weltkrieg oder gar den Einsatz von
Atomwaffen und auch die Ex
lieblingsängste von der kalten Wohnung
den schier unbezahlbaren Energie und
Lebenserhaltungskosten sind nicht
grundlos sie bergen sozialen Sprengstoff
und verlangen von uns zügig
praxistauglich und gerechter Antworten
manche mögen all diese Sorgen beiseiten
wischen und sagen der nächste Panzer
noch dann kommt es zum Frieden ich
glaube die militärlogik alleine löst es
nicht und ich muss Ihnen auch sagen auch
als überzeugter Anhänger von Abrüstung
und Friedenspolitik ich habe wie meine
gesamte Fraktion mitgestehen bei dem
Antrag der auch schweres militäres Gerät
liefert die Behauptungen
Entschließungsantrag dass wir hier
beschlossen nicht umgesetzt hätten ist
schlicht falsch und wird durch
Wiederholung nicht besser meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
und Führungsrolle heißt dass wir uns
beteiligen an humanitäre und
finanzieller Hilfe mit gutem Beispiel
vorangehen dass ein militärischer
Leistung das tun was wir gemeinsam tun
wollen aber wir wollen keine Alleingänge
machen nicht nur der Bundeskanzler nicht
die Bevölkerung will das übrigens auch
nicht lesen Sie mal die New York Times
Washington werden die gleichen
Diskussionen geführt ich habe noch nie
gehört dass beiden Verdächtige
putinfreund zu sein weil er ähnlich
formuliert wie der Bundeskanzler meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren und in
dieser Zeit gewaltige Herausforderung
darf man sich als Abgeordneter in der
Regierungsfraktion eine kritische aber
konstruktive
Oppositionen der staatsangebission
wünschen was haben wir ein frisch
gewählten Oppositionsführer über
angeblichen sozialtourismus-ukrainischer
Flüchtlinge herzieht sieht so ihre
Unterstützung für die Ukraine aus meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren ja am
Herz sie haben sich nach öffentlicher
Empörung halbherzig entschuldigt
Fachleute nennen sowas nonpology aber
das Hauptproblem ist nicht der Begriff
sozialtourismus sondern ihre Haltung die
dahinter stecken ihre Familien Äußerung
gegenüber vielen Ukrainern die vor Toten
Zerstörung flüchten die man ihrer
Angehörigen besuchen und die jede
Unterstützung verdienen und nicht den
Zynismus aus ihren Worten meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und schlimmer
noch
ein paar Tage vor der wichtigen
Landeswahlen in Niedersachsen haben ihre
Berater offenbar die Ansicht vertreten
dass eine in ein Stück
Fremdenfeindlichkeit noch ein paar
Prozentpunkte bringen können am rechten
Rand parallel wirbt ihr
stellvertretender CSU-Vorsitzender für
einen rechtsfaschistisches Bündnis in
Italien meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren sie haben keine Brandmauer nach
rechts sie haben eine Zeltplane oder
geht es links und rechts wieder raus
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
und das ist ein Problem in unserer
Situation die wir hier haben das war
klar und deutlich sagen
da gilt das was Helmut Schmidtmann über
Franz-Josef Strauß gesagt hat wenn man
sich nicht selbst beherrschen kann soll
man keine Verantwortung für dieses Land
übernehmen Herr Oppositionsführer das
will ich Ihnen ganz deutlich sagen wer
so redet vergiftet die Atmosphäre und
macht keine staatstragenden Opposition
aber zum Glück heißt der Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz er steuert besonders mit
ruhiger Hand des regierungsschiff in
schwere Wetterlage die Koalition besteht
aus drei verschiedenen Parteien ja wir
haben unterschiedliche Auffassung aber
wir sind zusammen bei dem was wir tun
und wir können gar nicht so schlecht
werden dass wir schlechter werden
könnten als sie ganz ehrlich mit allem
was wir tun wir werden uns einigen auf
die Dinge die wir tun und die
Bevölkerung kann sich darauf verlassen
dass wir abwägend handeln dass wir
entschlossen handeln dass wir im Bündnis
handeln und dass die Menschen sich auf
uns verlassen können bei ihnen sind sie
verlassen mit dem was sie tun ihr Anteil
ist überflüssig und wir Linien ab
sagt Ralf Stegner hat hier auch noch mal
wie schon Vorredner Friedrich Merz
angegriffen indirekt denn der hatte in
einem Interview von sozialtourismus
gesprochen hat sich für dieses Wort aber
entschuldigt wohl nicht ausreichend für
den einen oder die andere Abgeordnete
malte Kaufmann spricht jetzt für die
afd-fraktion Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren lassen Sie
mich zu Beginn zum wiederholten Male
ganz klar sagen die afd-fraktion
verurteilt den Krieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine aufs schärfste dies haben wir
immer wieder zum Ausdruck gebracht
sowohl hier im Plenum die auch in den
Ausschüssen
dieser Krieg ist für alle beteiligten
Menschen entsetzlich er produziert
unsägliches Leid und zwar auf allen
Seiten jeder weitere Tag dieses Krieges
bringt viel Leid und Tod mit sich und
deshalb müssen wir alles sinnvolle dafür
tun dass diese militärische
Auseinandersetzung möglichst bald
aufhört der Weg den die Union mit ihrem
Antrag der immer noch intensiveren
Waffenlieferungen gehen möchte ist aber
der falsche er führt direkt hinein
er führt direkt hinein in die weitere
militärische Eskalation und er
widerspricht der jahrzehntelang
bewährten Strategie Deutschlands keine
Waffen in akute Krisengebiete zu liefern
diejenigen die diesen brandgefährlichen
Weg beschreiten wollen wissen leider
nicht was sie damit in Wirklichkeit
anrichten sie glauben der russische
Präsident Putin sei mittlerweile
geschwächt er komme dort bei es komme
dort bald zum Umsturz und dann werde
alles wieder gut ich empfehle diesen
ahnungslosen ein gestern erschienenes
Interview mit Professor barbarowski der
einer der renommiertesten deutschen
Osteuropa Historiker ist
er sagt in aller Klarheit dass sich die
Reihen um Putin mittlerweile geschlossen
haben und man seitens der russischen
Regierung umso entschlossener an den
Kriegszielen festhalten wird je größer
die Bedrängnis von außen ist je größer
also der militärische Druckwert den die
NATO-Staaten zugunsten des nicht
nato-mitglieds Ukraine aufbauen umso
unberechenbarer werden die Reaktion sein
bis hin zu einer nuklearen Dimension die
zwingend verhindert werden muss
um den Krieg nun nicht weiter eskalieren
zu lassen sondern so schnell wie möglich
zu beenden
ist jetzt die Stunde der Diplomatie
gekommen
leider hat Deutschland seine früher
einmal errungene Stellung als Nation die
gute Beziehungen zu allen Ländern dieser
Erde unterhält verloren heute haben wir
eine Außenministerin die sich in
rhetorische Aufrüstung gefällt russland
werde ruiniert durch die Sanktionen so
beispielsweise sagt es Frau baerbock
voller Selbstgewissheit in die laufenden
Kameras komischerweise steigen jedoch
bei uns die Energiekosten ins
Unermessliche während Energiekonzerne in
Russland Rekordgewinne einstreichen
wir als AFD setzen auf Diplomatie der
vorliegende Entschließungsantrag der CDU
aber setzt auf militärische Eskalation
in ihrem Antrag Werte Kollegen sind auf
knapp zweieinhalb Seiten die Wörter
Waffen und Waffensysteme 19 mal zu lesen
davon sieben Mal schwere Waffen aber
kein einziges Mal das so wichtige Wort
der Diplomatie wie kann das sein
dabei muss es das Ziel diplomatischer
Bemühungen sein ein sofortiges Ende der
Kampfhandlungen herbeizuführen gefolgt
von Friedensverhandlungen für eine
langfristige stabile Koexistenz von
Russland und der Ukraine
statt einer weiteren Eskalation wünschen
wir uns eine Friedensinitiative das
könnten sie mal beantragen bei der
Bundesregierung beispielsweise im Rahmen
der OSZE sowie humanitäre
Hilfsleistungen lassen sie uns alles tun
um den Frieden in Europa
wiederherzustellen vielen herzlichen
Dank
malte Kaufmann war das für
[Applaus]
die Mission
in dieser Debatte zum
Entschließungsantrag und damit auch zur
Diskussion ob Deutschland mehr Waffen
liefern sollte an die Ukraine Markus
Faber spricht dazu jetzt für die
FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
216 Tage 216 Tage an die an dem die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer um ihr Leben
fürchten weil ihre Wohnhäuser
bombardiert werden Krankenhäuser und
Kindergärten ganze Städte werden im
Erdboden gleichgemacht putinstruppen
vergewaltigen morgen verüben
Kriegsverbrechen der brutalsten Art und
das alles mitten in Europa wir schreiben
heute eben auch Tag 216 an dem sich die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer zu Wehr
setzen gegen diese brutale Bedrohung sie
kämpfen für ein Leben in Frieden und
Freiheit und das nötigt uns großen
Respekt ab meine Damen und Herren
die Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer wollen
nicht im System Putin leben sie wollen
nicht in einem System leben das keine
freie Presse kennt sie wollen nicht in
einem System Putin leben dass keine
freien und unabhängigen Wahlen kennt und
sie wollen nicht in einem System Putin
Leben in dem man verhaftet wird wenn man
ein weißes Blatt Papier gegen Himmel und
die in den Himmel streckt die Menschen
in der Ukraine wollen all das nicht
daher kommt ihre unglaubliche Motivation
deshalb kämpfen sie diesen ungleichen
Kampf
bei den Gesprächen während meines
Besuchs ein Harke in kammertors in
slofianz wurde immer wieder eine Sache
sehr sehr klar das wirksamste Mittel um
den russischen Vormarsch aufzuhalten er
ist eine deutliche Intensivierung und
Beschleunigung von Waffenlieferungen an
die Verteidigung
ja sprechen Sie mal gerne bitte mit
verhindern
ich bin daher sehr dankbar dass diese
Bundesregierung ihre
sicherheitspolitischen Prioritäten neu
gesetzt hat und dass wir hier gemeinsam
daran arbeiten diese zeitenwände
umzusetzen meine Damen und Herren
spätestens
spätestens seit dem gemeinsamen Antrag
zur Lieferung von schweren Waffen vom 28
April besteht darüber hier im Haus auch
eine breite politische Einigkeit ich
möchte mich daher an dieser Stelle bei
allen bedanken die diese Einigung vom 28
April hier mitgetragen haben bei der SPD
bei den Grünen bei den Freien Demokraten
aber eben auch bei der oppositionellen
Union und deswegen sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
möchte mich mal auch ihrem Antrag von
heute zuwenden sie fordern hier mehr
Transparenz bezüglich der Abgabe von
sensitiven militärischen Material ich
hoffe dass wir sie das Internet kein
Neuland ist aber sie können dort
nachlesen was die Bundesrepublik
abgegeben hat weil es auf der Webseite
der Bundesregierung steht und das gilt
leider auch für viele weitere Punkte in
ihrem Antrag die bereits umgesetzt sind
die Bundesregierung engagiert sich in
ringtauschvereinbarung mit Griechenland
und der Slowakei schnellstmöglich werden
unterstützen und Kampfpanzer Posts Gerät
zur Verfügung gestellt Flugabwehr der
Gepard Panzer ist geliefert
singerraketen demnächst auch dass ihre
seeluftverteidigungssystem alles das ist
unterwegs alle diese Punkte können sie
streichen
artilleriesysteme sind bereits seit
Monaten sehr erfolgreich in Aktion das
auch das scheint an ihnen vorbeigegangen
zu sein letzte Woche erst wurden vier
zusätzliche panzerhaubötzen nebst
Munition zugesagt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ausgebildet wird in Deutschland
seit Monaten diese Ausbildung muss
fortgesetzt werden zum Beispiel an den
panzerwitzen beim Thema Munition liefert
Deutschland alle kalibergrößen unter
anderem auch die Vulcano Artillerie
Munition mit gesteigerter Reichweite das
können Sie alles nachlesen seit der
Veröffentlichung sparen Sie sich auch
den Weg zur geheimschutzstelle das war
ihnen laut Antrag auch sehr wichtig auf
dieser Punkt hat sich erledigt die
Koalition hat einen sonderstab-
ist damit auch dieser Punkt Geschichte
Radarsysteme
zum Beispiel Cobra kommen aus Beständen
der Bundeswehr alles nachlesbar 50
gepanzerte Waffensysteme Dingo
aufklärungsmittelschutzausrüstung
gewehrepanzerabwehrwaffen könnte das
hier endlos fortsetzen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen das ist ein sehr ernstes
Thema über das wir heute reden Menschen
sterben Menschen werden verwundet und
das verdankt auch eine ernsthafte
Auseinandersetzung mit dem Thema und
nicht diesen Antrag den Sie uns hier
vorlegen wir haben heute den 28
September und sie legen uns hier einen
Antrag vom 21 Juno vor hier steht wir
diskutieren ja gerade die
Regierungserklärung vom 22 juni das wird
der Ernsthaftigkeit das Thema ist nicht
gerecht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
deswegen fordere ich Sie auf nehmen Sie
sich mit putinskrieg der Ukraine nehmen
sich dem Thema ernsthaft an in den
Anfragen die sie hier vorlegen aber auch
in den Ausführungen die sie so tun und
werfen sie nicht Kriegsflüchtlingen
sozialtourismus vor dann wäre uns glaube
ich allen ja schon geholfen vielen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
als nächstes erhält das Wort André hunko
für die Linke andre hunko ist
europapolitischer Sprecher seiner
Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
Ende August stimmten 77 Prozent der
Menschen in Deutschland der Aussage zu
dass sie dafür sind
dass der Westen Verhandlungen über eine
Beendigung des Krieges einleitet wir
halten das für notwendig und richtig und
auch jetzt für richtig und leider ist
dahingehend in dieser Zeit überhaupt gar
nichts passiert im Gegenteil
wir erleben seit dieser Zeit seit Ende
August eine weitere Eskalation des
Krieges auf verschiedenen Ebenen und ein
Teil dieser Eskalation ist etwa die
Teilmobilmachung in Russland offiziell
mit 300.000 Reservisten wahrscheinlich
sind es noch mehr und wir sagen diese
Eskalation diese immer weitere
Eskalation und auch die Entgrenzung
dieses Krieges muss dringend verhindert
werden
[Applaus]
was diese Teilmobilmachung angeht wir
linken treten dafür ein dass
kriegsunwilligen aus Russland eine
unkomplizierte Aufnahme in Europa
ermöglicht wird übrigens auch
kriegsunwilligen aus Belarus und auch
der Ukraine und wir denken dass der
humanitäre Visa zum Beispiel notwendig
ist
ein weiterer Teil
der Eskalation der letzten Tage ist der
Anschlag auf die
Erdgaspipeline Nord Stream 1 und 2
wir wissen nicht genau was passiert ist
wir wissen dass es ein
höchstwahrscheinlich ein staatlicher
Akteur war aber wir denken dass es
dringend notwendig ist diesen Anschlag
der einen Anschlag ist auf die
Energiesicherheit auf die
Energieinfrastruktur in Deutschland und
Europa dass dieser Anschlag aufgeklärt
werden muss und deswegen mein Vorschlag
dass hier eine internationale
Untersuchungskommission eingerichtet
wird am besten wahrscheinlich im Rahmen
der OSZE weil dieser Anschlag ganz
dringend aufgeklärt werden muss
meine Damen und Herren wir brauchen
dringend einen Ausweg aus dieser immer
weitergehenden Eskalation ich sehe in
dem Antrag der cdu/csu leider auch einen
Schritt in Richtung weiterer Eskalation
wir brauchen den Weg zurück zur
Diplomatie wenigstens um die Entgrenzung
dieses Krieges zu verhindern besser noch
für einen Waffenstillstand noch besser
für einen Frieden aber es müssen
Schritte in diese Richtung unternommen
werden da findet gegenwärtig nichts
statt aber das fordere ich hier ein
vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
nächste Rednerin ist Sarah Nanni für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen meine Damen und Herren
Russland führt seinen Krieg gegen die
Ukraine in allen Dimensionen zu Luft zu
Land und zu See aber auch im Cyber und
Informationsraum Russland führt seinen
Krieg gegen die Ukraine mit allen
Mitteln Kampfhubschrauber Panzer und
Fregatten aber auch Hunger
Energieverknappung und Desinformation
wir sind in Deutschland zu Luft zu See
an Land nicht betroffen aber wir sind
betroffen wenn die Lebensmittelpreise
durch den Krieg hochgehen und auch
dadurch das Russland gezielt
Ackerflächen angreift wir sind betroffen
wenn der Gashebel zum
erpressungsinstrument werden soll wenn
kritische Infrastruktur angegriffen wird
und wir sind betroffen wenn es darum
geht die unterstützungsbereitschaft der
deutschen Bevölkerung für die Ukraine
durch Desinformation zu schmälern und da
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union haben sie diese Woche Russland
richtig in die Karten gespielt
ihr Fraktionsvorsitzender Sie Herr märz
unter Stellen in einem Interview bei
Bild TV Ukraine erinnern die vor dem
Krieg nach Deutschland fuhren
Sozialleistungen zu Unrecht in Anspruch
zu nehmen ich werde das Wort dass sie
dafür benutzt haben hier nicht
wiederholen was genau treibt sie da um
abgesehen davon das ist eine gängige
rechtsspopulistische Unterstellung
gegenüber geflüchteten im Allgemeinen
ist was treibt Sie da um wissen sie
wessen Spiel sie damit spielen
Putin weiß der kampfeswelle der Ukrainer
und auch die Unterstützung der Partner
der Ukraine haben dafür gesorgt auch mit
Waffen ja das Russland dabei ist diesen
Krieg zu verlieren
will Putin das Blatt wenden muss er bei
beidem ansetzen an der Moral der Ukraine
und der Unterstützung der Partner der
Ukraine
und Herr Merz und die Union helfen ihm
diese Woche natürlich ohne Absicht bei
beidem sie tun so als könne man den
ukrainen nicht über den Weg trauen
Katzen in der größten Oppositionspartei
als Parteivorsitzenden als
Parteivorsitzender der CDU der gerne
nach Kiew ins Baltikum fährt um sich als
Unterstützer der Ukraine zu inszenieren
sie sehen Zweifel an der Integrität von
Menschen die vor Krieg und Vernichtung
geflohen sind und Schutz in Deutschland
gesucht haben das ist ein Schlag ins
Gesicht aller geflüchtete aus der
Ukraine und es ist Wasser auf die Mühlen
derjenigen die sich wünschen Deutschland
Zwänge die Ukraine zu Kapitulation die
russische Propaganda nimmt es direkt auf
was für ein gefundenes Fressen von
Sicherheitspolitik des 21 jahrhunderts
da steht schon mal fest haben sie keine
Ahnung denn sonst wäre ihnen sowas nicht
passiert
zur Qualität des Antrags hat der Kollege
Faber gerade ausführlich ausgeführt
bleibt mir nur eins zu sagen gut dass
Friedrich Merz nicht Bundeskanzler ist
sich hier hauptsächlich in ihrer Rede
auf die Kritik an und des Volkes auch
konzentriert
giovanngarten spricht jetzt für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren uns liegt eher ein inhaltlich
veralteter und in seinen Zielen
weitgehend erledigter Antrag der cdu/csu
zur Debatte vor er belegt wie sprunghaft
ziellos und an der vermeintlichen
Tagesstimmung ausgerichtet die
außenwirtschafts-
die falsche Forderung des
Fraktionsvorsitzenden März aus dem
Frühjahr nach sofortigem Abnahme Stopp
für das russische Gas die
irrlichterinnen Vorschläge des
sächsischen Ministerpräsidenten nach
einer Annäherung an Russland dieser
Antrag der nichts mehr zu tun hat mit
der militärischen Realität der in der
Ukraine eine ununterbrochene Kette von
Fehleinschätzungen und falschen
Ratschlägen
in diesem Kontext gehören auch die
Äußerung des
cdu/csu-fraktionsvorsitzenden zum
angeblichen sozialtourismus von
ukrainischen Kriegsopfern in Deutschland
es ist das mindeste Herr Kollege Merz
diesen massiven politischen Fehler
einzugestehen aber dieses eigenständnis
muss auch Folgen für Stil und Inhalt der
Unionspolitik haben wir können Sie Herr
Kollege gleich damit anfangen kehren Sie
bitte zurück zur Sachlichkeit hören Sie
auf eine Verteidigungspolitik zu
kritisieren die Versäumnisse korrigiert
die unter 16 Jahren unionsverantwortung
entstanden sind
und verzichten Sie künftig auf die
Hybris und die Arroganz mit der sie die
Unterstützung der Bundesregierung und
insbesondere der
bundesverteidigungsministerin für die
Ukraine diskreditieren
[Applaus]
gemacht der Blutdruck so jung seid ihr
alle nicht mehr
denn dieser Antrag zeigt wie falsch sie
liegen Deutschland unterstützt die
Ukraine massiv mit entscheidenden
militärischen Material Panzerhaubitzen
LKW Gebhardt brückenpanzer Mars 2 isst
jetzt der Dingo die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte behaupten sie nie am Kampf
gerade auch aufgrund der strategisch
richtigen Unterstützung durch
Deutschland wir helfen dort wo es am
sinnvollsten ist bei der Logistik bei
der Luftabwehr und bei der Feuerkraft
der Artillerie und wir bleiben
gleichzeitig dabei dieser Krieg ist
militärisch begonnen worden aber er muss
politisch beendet werden dazu gehört die
vom Bundeskanzler
energisch betriebene Abstimmung mit
unseren g7-partnern genauso wie die
politische Unterstützung des
Widerstandes gegen das putin-regime und
Russland und der Ausbau weltweiter
Zusammenarbeit der demokratischen
Staaten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Antrag der cdu/csu zeigt es gibt keine
ernsthafte politische Alternative in
unserem Land zur Politik der
Ampelkoalition
Schwarzmalerei Aktionismus und die
Verängstigung der Bevölkerung zu schüren
sind keine sinnvolle Politik wir lehnen
den Antrag der Union deshalb ab und
Stimmen der Beschlussempfehlung des
Wirtschaftsausschusses zu vielen Dank
soweit Joe Weingarten
SPD-Fraktion ist der Redner ist Thomas
erndel cdu/csu-fraktion und
stellvertretender Vorsitzender im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich glaube wir müssen ja schon
mal eine ehrliche Debatte führen es kann
nicht sein dass Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der
Ampelkoalition in Talkshows in den
sozialen Medien immer eine komplett
andere Botschaft senden als sie hier in
diesem Parlament senden das ist doch
unglaublich es geht doch hier um das
Selbstverständnis des Parlaments und
wenn wir uns am 28 April genau vor fünf
Monaten einig waren da muss es doch auch
ihr Anspruch sein dass dieser Beschluss
auch von der Regierung umgesetzt wird es
kann auch nicht sein dass sie sich hier
hinstellen und sagen zehn haubitzenhaft
1.300 km Frontlinie ist eine
ausreichende Unterstützung des größten
und es wirtschaftsstärksten Landes in
diesem Kontinent
und das ist der Antrag heute zur
Abstimmung kommt es liegt auch an ihrer
Verzögerungstaktik und nicht an einer
ehrlichen inhaltlichen
Auseinandersetzung meine Damen und
Herren
ich gebe Ihnen
ich gebe Ihnen mal ein paar Anregungen
und vielleicht kann ich da auch noch
einen Einwurf machen ich zitiere gerne
aus einem Tweet des Kollegen Faber der
das ganze nochmal unterstreicht wie den
eigentlich die Situation ist im August
auf Deutsch übersetzt ich schäme mich
für mein Land es tut mir leid wir werden
versuchen besser zu werden ich glaube
besser kann man es auch nicht
zusammenfassen und beschreiben wie
unsere Unterstützung der Ukraine
ausschaut ich gebe Ihnen mal ein paar
Anregungen weil die Dinge nämlich
glasklar vor einem liegen dass die
Atomkraftwerke nötig sind damit wir gut
durch den Winter kommen liegt auch
glasklar vor uns dass die gasumlage
kontraproduktiv ist liegt glasklar vor
uns und trotzdem streitet zögert und
Zara diese Regierung und es ist genauso
bei der Unterstützung der Ukraine
die Ukraine kann nur mit massiver
Unterstützung von uns weiter bestehen
und das liegt auch glasklar auf dem
Tisch und es liegt ebenso glasklar auf
dem Tisch dass es nie wieder eine
Zusammenarbeit mit Putins Russland geben
kann und wird und es ist auch absolut
unvorstellbar dass auch nur ein
Quadratmeter ukrainisches Territorium
und der russischer Kontrolle verbleibt
und die Botschaft an die Führung im
Moskau muss doch sein egal was du tust
egal was du mit was du drohst es wird
nicht erfolgreich sein und das sind wir
eben an einem Wendepunkt in der
Geschichte an dem Deutschland
Führungsstärke beweisen muss Führung die
jetzt einfach nicht sichtbar ist Führung
die
Taten statt Worte braucht und wo die
Taten auch der Zielsetzung entsprechen
müssen es kann doch nicht sein dass die
Bundesregierung als Zielsetzung ausgibt
dass die ukrainischen Truppen die Russen
vertreiben sollen das Ukraine diesen
Krieg gewinnen muss und dann eben nicht
mit allen Möglichkeiten
Ukraine unterstützt ein ukrainischer
Sieg und damit Frieden in Europa kann
eben nicht erreicht werden wenn wir die
Ukraine nicht alle Fähigkeiten geben
alle Möglichkeiten geben ihn zu
erkämpfen und da brauchen wir Nägel mit
Köpfen und da müssen endlich Fahrten
folgen
wir brauchen endlich
eine
unterstützungskonferenz eine dauerhafte
unterstützungskonferenz unter der
Führung Deutschlands die sicherstellt
dass wir erstens die Ukraine kurzfristig
mit allem bei der industrieverfügbaren
Material unterstützen das heißt grünes
Licht für Marder und Leopard 1 die
zweiten sicherstellt dass wir dauerhaft
in drei sechs und allen 12 Monaten noch
unterstützen und liefern können ich habe
nicht gesehen dass die lokrine
gelieferten Haubitzen oder auch die
atheniegeschosse nachbestellt wurden das
ist ein Armutszeugnis meine Damen und
Herren und drittens müssen wir auch für
mehr Kampfkraft mit Leopard 2 sorgen
eine Gemeinschaftsaktion wie es
Wissenschaft und auch Kollegen der
ampelfraktion vorgeschlagen haben und
viertens und ich komme dann auch zum
Ende meine Frau Präsidentin und viertens
braucht es bereits auch jetzt die
Konzeption wie die ukrainische Armee in
der Zukunft ausgestattet ist eine Armee
die eine Abschreckungswirkung entfalten
muss dass die wieder ein feindlicher
Soldat es wagt ukrainisches viele Totem
zu betreten meine Damen und Herren das
ist doch das was Europa von Deutschland
erwartet das ist das was führung
bedeutet und dann brauchen wir auch
keine weiteren Anträge stellen wenn die
Regierung endlich mal beherzt auch die
Dinge in die Hand nimmt führung bedeutet
dass wir jetzt
aber nicht sie müssen jetzt schon zum
Schluss kommen am Ende führung bedeutet
dass wir jetzt die Kräfte der Freiheit
mit Nachdruck und ein schlosszeit
unterstützen es geht um das
Selbstverständnis des Parlaments und
deswegen bitte ich um Unterstützung für
den Antrag herzlichen Dank
so und damit kommen wir hier zum letzten
Redner wir sehen auch das Plenum hat
sich deutlich gefüllt denn gleich steht
einen namentliche Abstimmung an vorher
spricht allerdings noch Bernd Westphal
für die SPD frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren von der Union
bitte hören Sie auf mit ihren Phrasen
hier Deutschland würde nicht genug tun
wir stehen an der Seite der Ukraine der
Menschen dort die sich tapfer
verteidigen wir kommen unseren
Verpflichtungen nach sie reiten ein
totes Pferd steigen Sie bitte ab davon
diese diese Bundesregierung unter der
Führung von Olaf Scholz versucht in den
Bündnissen auf europäischer Ebene in der
Präsidentschaft der G7 und natürlich
auch in der NATO genau diese
Geschlossenheit diesen Zusammenhalt zu
organisieren den es heute braucht genau
um diese Hilfe zu organisieren und wir
haben seit dem 24 februar eine Situation
wo diese Geschlossenheit noch nie so
deutlich war wie jetzt und das ist auch
ein Verdienst von unserem Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren
alle Ministerien und alle Ministerinnen
und Minister dieser ampelregierung
versuchen genau das zu organisieren dass
wir Sicherheit in dieser schwierigen
Situation haben in einer historisch
schwierigen Situation unsere Wirtschaft
so stabilisieren dass wir Arbeits- und
Ausbildungsplätze
dementsprechend in die Zukunft führen
und dass wir vor allen Dingen dafür
sorgen dass wir dieses Land sicher mit
Energie beliefern können und das hat
damit zu tun dass zum Beispiel in einem
enormen Tempo jetzt lng-terminals gebaut
werden weil wir spätestens seit gestern
wissen dass wir von Russland keine
Energie mehr durch die Pipeline bekommen
werden und deshalb ist das richtig diese
Infrastruktur aufzubauen und auch mit
unseren europäischen Partnern dafür zu
sorgen dass wir diese
Energieversorgungssicherheit darstellen
Herr Abgeordneter lassen Sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der
in einem weiteren Bereich
international wird dafür gesorgt dass
Energie eingekauft wird das ist genau
das wo wir jetzt ein Angebot erhöhen
müssen dass wir Stabilität kriegen bei
der Preis bei den Preisen und vor allen
Dingen in der Versorgungssicherheit
diese Regierung hat auch dazu
beigetragen dass wir mit
Rahmenbedingungen unsere speichern
füllen dass wir jetzt Erdgas zur
Verfügung haben um durch den nächsten
Winter zu kommen und genau das verdient
diese Bundesregierung dann Unterstützung
weil sie eben an diesen Dingen auch
arbeiten und wir im Parlament in die
Rahmenbedingungen dafür geben
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
der März
wenn Menschen fliehen vor Bomben vor
Panzer vor zerstörter Infrastruktur dann
ist das mehr als zynisch das als
sozialtourismus zu beschreiben ich kann
Ihnen nur sagen ich kann Ihnen nur sagen
diese Brandmauer gegen Rechts ist ihre
Aufgabe auch als Vorsitzender der
größten Oppositionspartei sie nennen
sich christlich ich kann Ihnen nur sagen
was ist das für ein Menschenbild sie
nennen das vielleicht Nächstenliebe aber
ich kann Ihnen sagen dass das was ich in
diesem Land erlebe ist eine humane
Orientierung in den 90er Jahren als wir
die Menschen vom Balkan hier aufgenommen
haben als sie geflohen sind wir haben
2015 Menschen aus Syrien hier
aufgenommen und es ist jetzt eine
Solidarität eine Menschlichkeit die wir
hier in unserem Land erkennen die dafür
sorgen genau diese menschliche
Orientierung zu erleben und deshalb bin
ich froh dass diese Gesellschaft anders
denkt als sie sie haben sich mit diesen
disqualifiziert auf dem Stuhl mit der
hohenlehne Platz zu nehmen herzlichen
Dank
vielen Dank
zum zusatztopf 2 liegt eine Erklärung
zur Abstimmung nach § 31 unserer
Geschäftsordnung vor
wir kommen zur Abstimmung über die
Beschlussempfehlung des
Wirtschaftsausschusses auf Drucksache
27,12 zu dem Entschließungsantrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu auf Drucksache 23
47 und hören Sie doch bitte zu dann
fragen sie dich noch mal nach also die
Fraktion der CDU CSU hat
namentliche Abstimmung verlangt die
Abstimmung erfolgt wie gewohnt in der
westlobby und sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer
Stimme 20 Minuten Zeit die
Schriftführerin und Schriftführer sind
an ihren Plätzen damit können wir dann
auch die namentliche Abstimmung eröffnen
über die Beschlussempfehlung die
abstimmungsurnen werden um 18 Uhr wieder
geschlossen